欢迎你学习白泽国际站运营实战系统课
第二小节我们来讲一下什么样的产品放有橱窗它的效果会更好
橱窗其实就是对产品标题中的每一个关键词的排名都有加权的作用
让好的产品排名更靠前
这是橱窗的核心的作用
就是提升它的排名
提升关键词的排名
那么我们应该选择什么样的产品
下面这三个条件就是我们要选产品的一个参考标准
第一个就是关键词的覆盖率
也就是说比如说你A款产品的链接有一个链接
那么这是它的标题
标题里面有A, B, C, D, E, F等等组合成的一个标题
那么这个标题里面能够覆盖的关键词越多
那么我们把这样的A产品加入橱窗
那么它能够对我们的关键词的覆盖率的整体的排名有更大的促进作用
也就是如果你A产品加入了橱窗之后
你会发现它的这个标题里面组合的这么多关键词的排名都有一定的拉伸作用
A, D, C, D, E, F, 这些都是组合成这个标题的所有的关键词, 那么如果这个产品, A 产品, 加入了这个
橱窗之后, A 关键词可能原来排名在
第20名,如果你加的橱窗可能排名在前20, B 之前排名可能在30名, 如果你加入橱窗, 那么这个产品加入橱窗, 那么你这个
B的关键词排名可能就在前30名, 所以说他对
这个
A产品
这个标题里面的所有的关键词都有拉升排名的一个促进作用,但是呢
并不是所有的关键词都能够得到
排名的提升,因为这个还要看你跟同王的竞争情况,所以说
对于
这里面的这些标题的关键词
可能有些有排名更好,有些
排名是没有什么变化
所以这个逻辑大家一定要理解清楚
第二种情况呢就是
加入橱窗的产品,我们可以选择新品, 优品, 还有就是爆品
这些产品为什么要优先加入橱窗呢?因为新品
它是一个有三个月的流量的扶持期
所以如果我们前期就把
这些新品加入橱窗,那么对于它所有的标题的关键词都有
一定的提升作用,让我们的新品能够在更短的时间内测试出哪些更具有爆品的潜力, 那么优品和爆品为什么要加入橱窗优先呢?因为这些产品它本身具备一定的数据沉淀数据积累, 那么它的单品的权重是比较大的, 如果你加入橱窗, 那么对于这些优品跟爆品标题里面的
所有的关键词的排名促进的作用更大
所以说你要优先加入这些产品
第三个呢就是高转化的低曝光量的产品加入橱窗
高转化也就是我们说的循环TM可能比较多
但是这个产品曝光量少也就是被人看到的机会少
我们通过把这个产品加入橱窗
就是为了提升它的排名,你排在月前面是不是能够让更多的人看到,那么让更多的人看到是不是它的转化率可能会更多一点,更高一点呢,所以说我们选择产品的时候就从这三个维度去选择就可以了,最后我们来理解一个原理就是
就是, 橱窗是给大量的关键词排名加权的, 是提升关键词的排名, 同时提升产品的排名, 因为关键词的排名就是产品的排名, 关键词排在前面, 那么产品肯定就是排在前面的, 所以说我们要把这个原理记住, 同时我们选品的时候, 也要按照这个逻辑去选品就可以了,